the year is 3855 a seventeen-year-old
girl named Alexa and her younger brother
Asher are at a museum of history and
Technology in one of the museum's
display rooms there is a collection of
ancient computers laptops tablets
smartphones and other early smart
devices a few of which have been
maintained and restored in order to
still function specifically one laptop
on display is set up for visitors to use
on it there are old digital tools used
for things like information storage
digital art creation communication and
personal upkeep as well as browser
applications used to access early forms
of the Internet as part of the
experience the laptop has a sequence of
default archival web pages that pertain
to the exhibit which is about early
stage digital content creation and
internet communication Alexa and Asher
play around on the laptop for a little
while their parents participate in
another exhibit while scrolling through
the internet pages they come across a
webpage of a video sharing platform with
the video titled Internet video of an
animated voiceover the description of
the video reads this video is an excerpt
from what is believed to be an interview
speech podcast or self produced video
essay created between the late 20th and
early 22nd century it simply serves as a
sample for how individuals sought to use
the internet to communicate during its
early stages of development and
integration the source of the video is
unknown due to digital dissemination
false attributions synthetic media
replications and possible intentional
and anima T Alexa clicks play in the
video starts
[Applause]
one last question when it's all said and
done how would you like to be remembered
it's sort of a funny question isn't it
asking how you want to be remembered
after you're gone no one ever knows how
they're remembered
nor does anyone ever experience it and
yet for some reason we still ask
ourselves these sorts of questions it's
a paradox really to want something after
I'm dead
but only be able to want anything while
I'm alive the question is really more
about what I want to imagine while I'm
alive then isn't it what I want to
convince myself my life could be for
beyond my own life seeing as how I can
only imagine beyond my own life while my
own life still exists if I were to
humour the question though I don't think
I would want to claim any sort of banal
grandiose answers I don't think I would
want to say that I want to be remembered
as significant or influential or smart
or famous or wealthy or powerful or
successful or that I changed the world
in some way all of that would suggest
that I can know what any of that even
means in the bigger picture and truth I
don't know what it means to be
influential in a world that lacks clear
direction I don't know what it means to
be wealthy in a world filled with
poverty I don't know what it means to be
powerful in a universe that trumps
everyone and everything and I don't know
what it means to be smart or successful
or to change the world as a member of a
species that's restricted from
understanding what anything might really
mean or cause I suppose I'm attracted to
these things as much as the next person
but I cannot say with certain honesty
that I believe that in the end any of
these things are worth being remembered
for I guess the next answer would be
that I want to be remembered as someone
who tried someone who tried their best
to care to help to love to be okay to
err on the side of sympathy and
compassion as best I could to be a good
friend good son father and husband
someone who lived honestly with both
conviction and a willingness to adapt in
what they think and believe someone who
contributed towards something they
enjoyed and believed in simply because
they could I'm not entirely sure how
good I was at any of these things though
and I know that this answer might sound
equally cliche but if anything is an
answer to how I want to be remembered I
think it's that but the truth is history
is coated with enumerable amounts of
people who lived with these qualities
and mostly none of them are
by anyone at all perhaps being
remembered isn't all that important then
if most people aren't remembered for
what's important of course some people
are remembered long after they're gone
for things that do currently seem
important or useful but even then if one
is remembered because they've done
something that's considered useful isn't
it the useful thing that is truly being
remembered and not the person in it of
themselves I mean how does anyone know
Albert Einstein if not in terms of
scientific contribution it's not as if
the world likes Einstein inherently the
world likes his contributions or him
solely because of his contributions any
exploration of his character and life
has always contextualized or confined
within the borders of science genius in
the eyes of history Einstein would be no
one if it were not for his scientific
contributions but of course Einstein was
not no-one regardless of his
contributions his contributions deserve
celebration of course and so does he but
does our celebration of him now change
anything for him then I don't know if
Einstein was happy or if he wanted to be
remembered in some grand way or if he
just wanted to understand more than what
was understood at the time but isn't it
possible that his contributions are a
byproduct of his experience of life and
not the source and isn't it possible
that this is the case for all people
that are remembered as great throughout
history I'll certainly admit that
there's some longing inside me to be
remembered or thought of long after I'm
gone I believe it probably comes from
the same place that yearns to live
forever and lose nothing but nothing
lives forever
and everyone loses everything to live
for or care about being remembered is
like planning your own birthday party on
a day that you can't go if I want to
celebrate my life I can only do it now
while I'm still here I believe everyone
should still dedicate themselves to the
something or some things that they want
to be remembered for be it a cause a
passion a good heart or all of the above
but not because it's something that
they'll be remembered for but because
it's what they want to imagine their
life is for and what you imagine your
life is for is what your life is for
isn't it whether one is remembered for
it for five hundred thousand years or
five minutes after they're gone
makes no difference to the person who
lived for it
ultimately I have no illusions that I
will last beyond the minds of a couple
generations after me at best and so what
I do now what I dedicate myself to what
I experience behind the eyes of my own
self must be enough if it isn't nothing
is
the video fades to its end in the screen
prompts an arrow pointing to the right
with text that reads next page before
clicking Asher says well that's five
minutes we'll never get back he pauses
and then says and who's Einstein yeah I
don't know Alexa replies I think you
must have been a scientist or something
I think I've heard his name before
that's what it said Elise hmm
Asher murmurs all right well do you want
to go check out something else now
Asher concludes Alexa agrees and they
walk away from the laptop and on to the
next exhibit of a different time in
history
[Music]
you